vous nous avez demandé si c'est vrai que
c'est pas sécuritaire de manger une
préparation à gâteaux avant la cuisson
en effet parce que la farine n'a
peut-être pas l'apparence d'un aliment
du loup et pourtant elle l'est il faut
se rappeler que la farine provient de
céréales cultivées dans les champs où
elles peuvent être contaminés par des
bactéries présentes dans le sol ou dans
l'eau comme le colibri exemple et il n'y
a que la chaleur pour les détruire
aussi quand on préparer une pâte à
gâteau on ajoute souvent des oeufs crus
qui eux pourraient être potentiellement
contaminés à la salmonelle
c'est précaution s'applique aussi aux
préparations du commerce que ce soit des
mélanges à gâteau âme à feu doux à
crêpes d'ailleurs la plupart des
fabricants l'indiquent sur l'emballage